- I'm gonna win.
- No you're not.
- [Voiceover] Remember “Finding Nemo,”
the movie that introduced us to clownfish?
- Love you, dad.
- [Voiceover] Dory, the
absent-minded sidekick,
now has her own movie, but
marine conservationists,
they're not excited.
They're actually kind of worried.
This right here is a blue
tang, the real-life Dory.
They only live on coral
reefs in the south Pacific.
But before we get to her story,
let's talk about Nemo, the clownfish.
When “Finding Nemo” came out...
Well, okay, I'll let Karen tell you.
- I'm Karen Burke Da Silva.
I'm a marine biologist and
a conservation biologist
here at Flinders University
of South Australia.
- [Voiceover] So what
happened with “Finding Nemo?”
- After the release of “Finding Nemo,”
we found that there was
quite a big increase
in the number of people that
wanted a clownfish as a pet.
With the increase in demand, it did have
an increase in captive breeding,
but it also meant that more fish
were being taken from
the wild, and in fact,
some places there's been
so much over-collecting
that clownfish have gone locally extinct.
- [Voiceover] Oh, so captive breeding
seems like the way to go.
Back to Dory, the blue tang.
If her movie has the
same effect as Nemo's,
moviegoers are sure to want to
buy a blue tang of their own.
- But there's a problem.
- [Voiceover] And you are?
- My name is Matt DiMaggio.
I'm an assistant professor
at the University of Florida
Tropical Aquaculture Laboratory.
- [Voiceover] Ah, okay,
Matt, so what's the problem?
- Clownfish are relatively
easy to raise in captivity.
But up until now, no one has
raised blue tangs in captivity.
Blue tang larvae are
inherently difficult to raise.
They have a very small
mouth when they hatch out,
so the food particles
that we have to offer them
are much smaller and much
more difficult to raise.
The best success we've had to date
is using a zooplankton called copepod.
The copepods that we grow here
only eat live micro-algae,
so you now have to grow live micro-algae
to feed to the copepods.
- [Voiceover] Basically,
raising blue tangs so far
is really, really hard, which means...
- 100% of blue tang are
currently being taken
from the wild for the aquarium trade.
Most collectors in Australia will use
very careful collecting measures.
In other parts of the
world, southeast Asia,
they are using cyanide still
to collect aquarium fish.
- [Voiceover] Hmmm, that's not
good, but there's hope.
Matt and his team are working hard
to breed blue tangs successfully.
- There's only one other tang
species, the yellow tang,
that's ever been raised
in captivity before.
We're hoping that the blue
tang will be the second.
- [Voiceover] Alright, so until they do,
when little Johnny says he wants a Dory,
perhaps the better
choice, for now at least,
is to stick to the blue
betta… or a goldfish.
(light music)